[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden aprobó la declaración de
emergencia y ayuda Federal para el
Estado de Mississippi donde se
registraron 25 muertos tras el paso de
un fuerte tornado otra víctima fue
registrada en Alabama
el expresidente argentino Mauricio macri
no se presentará en las elecciones
presidenciales del mes de octubre de
esta manera el ex mandatario termina con
las especulaciones de que buscaría una
revancha luego de ser Derrotado por
Alberto Fernández en 2019
mercosur cumple 32 años de existencia el
mercado común del sur integrado por
Argentina Brasil Paraguay y Uruguay
ahora se acerca a la ratificación de un
acuerdo con la Unión Europea tras más de
20 años de negociaciones
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden declaró el estado de
catástrofe Mississippi y ordenó ayuda
Federal para la recuperación de varios
condados allí al menos 26 personas
perdieron la vida una de ellas en
Alabama y decenas resultaron heridas
tras el paso de varios tornados que
dejaron una Estela de destrucción y
dolor
una ciudad que desapareció por la furia
de la naturaleza la Brian Knight camina
por los escombros de Rolling fork una
pequeña ciudad al oeste de Mississippi
con menos de 2000 habitantes aquí nació
y creció y este fin de semana él y su
familia sobrevivieron al poder de un
tornado F4 uno de los más violentos Y
destructivos del que se tenga registro
las luces se apagaron y oí un gran
sonido las ventanas volaron los
escombros nos golpeaban
el servicio meteorológico nacional en
Jackson Mississippi informó que el
tornado permaneció en tierra durante
aproximadamente una hora y abrió una
Estela de destrucción de unos 274
kilómetros
puedes ver ese camión allí es de mi
hermano es camionero todos esos camiones
de ahí son sus camiones
[Música]
el momento más aterrador de mi vida fue
aterrador pensé que no íbamos a
sobrevivir porque este árbol de ahí
estaba en realidad en nuestro patio
trasero si hubiera pasado por encima de
la mitad trasera de la casa
probablemente no estaría aquí sentada
hablando contigo
el presidente Joe biden aprobó la
declaración de emergencia para el Estado
de Mississippi un mecanismo que
permitirá a los locales acceder a
subvenciones para alojamiento Temporal y
reparaciones de viviendas pese a la
rápida respuesta el peligro aún no
termina el centro de predicciones de
tormentas del servicio meteorológico
nacional advirtió que Mississippi
Alabama aún podrían enfrentar fuertes
vientos granizo y posibles tornados
vamos a Argentina el expresidente
Mauricio macri anunció que no será
candidato a las elecciones
presidenciales que se llevarán a cabo el
próximo mes de octubre de esta manera el
ex mandatario pone fin a las
especulaciones sobre su posible
candidatura antes de que se celebren las
primarias en agosto en las que cada
frente político definirá Quiénes eran
sus aspirantes a convertirse en
presidente del país
este domingo el mercado común del sur
conocido como mercosur cumple 32 años de
existencia una Unión económica de
Argentina Brasil Paraguay y Uruguay que
ha tratado de generar una mayor
competitividad mediante la integración
con ese objetivo se acerca a la
ratificación de un acuerdo con la Unión
Europea a continuación nos adentramos en
estos acuerdos con esta pieza de
corresponsales de France 24
esta fábrica produce autopartes en
Buenos Aires actualmente funciona a
pleno rendimiento las exportaciones del
sector aumentaron un 11,6% en 2022 sin
embargo temen que esto se revierta
después del acuerdo entre mercosur y la
Unión Europea el sector Automotriz
podría ser el más afectado por el
acuerdo ya que la industria en Europa es
más competitiva y moderna y sus
vehículos no tendrían aranceles así lo
explican desde la asociación de fábricas
argentinas de componentes que
representan a más de 200 empresas para
un sector con más de 55.000 personas
empleadas que no hay inversión implica
que luego la producción de ciertos
productos ya no se haga o de ciertos
productos de nueva con nuevas
tecnologías se decida que no se hacen
acá se hacen en Europa eso implica que
va a haber menos demanda de mano de obra
en Uruguay el país vecino desde hace más
de 50 años Lancer
uniformes para empresas de todo el mundo
mercosur fue muy importante para el
textil uruguayo sobre todo durante
periodos de estabilidad ahora Uruguay
estudia un tratado de libre comercio con
china al margen de mercosur la cámara de
la vestimenta de Uruguay teme que el
sector pueda desaparecer con ese acuerdo
por la diferencia competitiva
pantalones a una camisa algunas cosas
que todavía se siguen fabricando en
Uruguay y donde todavía somos un poco
competitivos así como estamos
Este Ahora sí de golpe desaparecen los
recargos y eso sería ya el punto final
de la industria
a sus 32 años mercosur espera ratificar
en Julia el acuerdo con la Unión Europea
mientras discuten con Uruguay un acuerdo
con china en conjunto o uno separado que
podría resquebrajar La Unión
este sábado falleció a los 88 años el
actor y comediante mexicano Xavier López
conocido por su personaje Chabelo un
niño que conducía un programa televisivo
que se mantuvo en emisión durante 48
años y que le permitió ser conocido en
todo el continente americano veamos su
historia
México despide al Amigo de todos los
niños el actor y conductor mexicano
Javier López Rodríguez falleció el
sábado a los 88 años de edad es un día
muy muy muy triste para nosotros para
mucha gente su doctor de cabecera el
Doctor Carlos Soto lo Atendió y ahí se
descubrió que el problema no era
pulmonar ni respiratorio sino abdominal
presentando un cuadro de abdomen agudo y
más adelante un choque séptico
que le quitó la vida
Amigo de todos los niños el 26 de
noviembre de 1967 se estrenó En familia
con Chabelo un programa que estuvo casi
medio siglo al aire y rompió récords en
la televisión mexicana
[Música]
Javier interpretaba el personaje por el
que será recordado para siempre un niño
de voz aguda y pantalones cortos que con
Su carisma cautivaba a las familias
mexicanas pese a sus 192 metros de
estatura Chabelo logró conquistar el
corazón de los mexicanos pese a no haber
nacido en México nació el 17 de febrero
de 1935 en Chicago Estados Unidos
siempre conservó la nacionalidad de
estadounidense y hasta prestó servicio
militar allí empezó la carrera de
Medicina pero la dejó para trabajar como
ayudante en un programa de televisión y
ahí nació el niño Chabelo Televisa
informó que retransmitirá el programa En
familia con Chabelo y películas del
actor Javier López Rodríguez y hasta el
presidente dio sus condolencias abrazo a
familiares y amigos por el fallecimiento
de Javier López Chabelo Cómo olvidar que
mi hijo mayor se despertaba temprano
para verlo hace más de 40 años su
familia pidió privacidad para despedirlo
en Ecuador quitó acogió este fin de
semana La séptima convención
internacional de tatuajes al acudieron
tatuadores de todo el mundo los
organizadores tienen como objetivo
Mostrar esta práctica como un arte más
detalles con Luis Muñoz
un demonio que esconde una geisha un
perro
y hasta el recuerdo para una madre los
hay de todos los tamaños y colores te
identifican te valora te relaciona te da
un algo distinto que es lo que la gente
que estamos tatuados buscamos vernos
distintos Nosotros somos un lienzos que
coleccionamos los mejores piezas de los
mejores tatuadores entonces para
nosotros es un ser un Lienzo y llevar
nuestra piel los mejores lienzos
y todo ha sido este fin de semana la
capital mundial del tatuaje una práctica
que tiene miles de años de antigüedad y
millones de adeptos para algunos
tatuarse es una terapia yo tengo muchos
clientes que cuando están atravesando
algo durante su vida alguna ruptura
alguna cosa se quieren tatuar que es
como una especie de ritual donde uno
sana enfatiza con el tatuador se libera
el evento además contó con un invitado
especial el francés Anthony lofredo
conocido como Black allian por las
modificaciones en su cuerpo con las que
busca asemejarse a un extraterrestre es
un proyecto que yo tengo de este pequeño
nadie mucho la atención la vida fuera de
la planeta me llama mucho la atención Yo
me pregunto siempre todos los días si
hay algo fuera que existe para mí sí es
como mi creyente es como si esta es mi
son el encuentro tiene por objetivo
hacer pedagogía sobre el universo del
tatuaje y romper los temores que todavía
rodean a este arte
hasta aquí es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]